تركيا توصل عرقله انضمام السويد الى حلف
الناتو في المقابل تصر الاخيره على ضروره
تعزيز روابطها العسكريه مع حلفائها
الغربيين طبعا تمهيدا للانضمام للحلف بناء
عليه تعمل ستوكهولم على ابرام اتفاقيه
عسكريه مع واشنطن لتحقيق تعاون اوثق مع
الولايات المتحده على الصعيدين الثنائي
وفي اطار حلف شمال الاطلسي حسب وزاره
الدفاع السويديه وزير الدفاع السويدي
جونسون افاده بان الاتفاقيه الجديده
ستسهل على القوات الامريكيه العمل داخل
الحدود السويديه من خلال توفير اماكن
لتخزين العتاب الدفاعي وكذلك القيام
باستثمارات في البناء التحتيه لتفعيل
الدعم بين الدولتين بالاضافه الى الوضع
القانوني للجنود الامريكيين في السويد